well this a few months ago big tech
texted tested its powers by blacklisting
alex jones from every major tech
platform all at once no one really said
anything about it because alex jones you
we're not allowed to like him or to
think it's okay these d platform so of
course the technology were emboldened
and if they can sounds one person why
not silence more and of course now they
are Jesse Kelly is a two-time
congressional candidate host radio show
in Houston just a few months ago he came
on this show and predicted that Twitter
eventually would censor him you wrote
this piece that I thought was really
compelling about Alex Jones and you said
look I don't agree with Alex Jones his
views but that's not the point the point
as you articulated was if you can
silence this guy cuz you don't like what
he says why can't they silence you or me
that is the point Tucker and they're
coming for you and me next well Kelly
turned out to be right just this past
Sunday yesterday Twitter shut down his
account and they did not explain why
tonight we're trying to find out what
happened Jesse Kelly joins us live
Jesse thanks off for coming on you knew
this was coming you presciently
predicted it
why did Twitter take you off its
platform nobody knows what Twitter
kicked me off the platform because I was
a mainstream voice on the right that
spoke the truth Tucker and that's all
anybody knows they've given me no
explanation as they told Congress they
would give explanations I all they sent
was an email that said you were
permanently banned and you can't appeal
it for repeated rules violations only I
don't violate their rules I don't cost
it people on there I don't harass people
on there I don't do any of those ugly
things that some people do so Twitter's
going to become what they are all of a
sudden my account vanished like a
Hillary Clinton email did you call them
if I mean it's not let me just say if
you're in your business or my business
that's not a small thing I mean that's
the way one of the ways that you
communicate with your listeners one of
the ways you disseminate your ideas the
main way you do so did you call Twitter
to find out or have any contact with
them at all no number to call in fat
once they banished your account it
wasn't a suspension they completely
banished me so I'm not even able to log
in an email Twitter's support a friend
of mine sent me a couple email addresses
for people that supposedly work at
Twitter but I'm sure they're not gonna
answer any of those it's they just they
did exactly what I said they would do
they came for Alex Jones first because
he's a nut job and they wanted to see
how the right would react they got him
and not knew they were coming for me
they'll come for you too so when when
they did come for Alex Jones the idea
was well you know you can have him
because he's embarrassing and no one
really said anything about it in a in my
opinion a very cowardly in stupid way do
you think if conservatives are not even
conserve people who dissent from the
conventional view of everything that
we're now required to believe at
gunpoint if though if the rest of us
starts to complain do you think we can
push back against censorship I think we
can and I think that's where the real
power is see it's not a big deal that I
got kicked off Twitter it hurts Twitter
worse than it hurt me because they
finally kicked off somebody that woke
everybody on the right up people were
now starting to realize what twitter has
become twitter is nothing but a platform
it's a blank piece of paper that somehow
one day woke up and decided that they
were the artist that they were in
control of what gets put on that piece
of paper and that's not where their
power lies so if they continue along
this path it's gonna be nothing but two
feminists screaming each other because
one of them accidentally found a
boyfriend am i misunderstanding this or
do that do the social media platforms
have a congressional exemption that
allows them not to be held legally
responsible of things that are said on
their platform there in other words
they're not media companies and they
can't be sued as media companies can be
sued but now they're acting like media
companies how does that work how it
works is they have the best of both
worlds you have it exactly right they
are treated like media platforms meaning
they are just an open site where people
can post what they want as long as
they're not inciting violence only
they're acting like thing progress
they're acting like the New York Times
because these radical voices on the left
never get censored even Farrakhan that
completes scumbag that has a tweet still
up comparing Jews to termites he still
has an
but I post things about Velveeta and
mine gets banished Jessie thank you for
that I appreciate it